[Music]
you've been on this program many times
you have played instruments for us what
surprised me is it with the intrument
that you're really serious about his
banjo hmm and I didn't know that you're
mean
you're a serious banjo player what
initially attracted you to the banjo
what makes a kid say that's what I want
to do play the banjo chicks I knew I
could get chicks yeah the banjo yeah not
true you didn't need to say that here's
the fun here's the first place that I I
mean I grew up going to I'm from Georgia
but I went to summer camp in North
Carolina and the in the Smoky Mountains
and it's so beautiful up there and
that's a sort of the cradle of a lot of
that music banjo is at bluegrass and all
that so that's kind of where I was first
exposed but but one of the first places
that where a lot of people got
introduced to bluegrass was the movie
deliverance yeah which which is a
disturbing movie yes with wonderful
music yes and famous Dueling Banjos yeah
from deliverance yeah and the what the
first time I saw the movie deliverance
was okay this is a interesting factoid
the movie deliverance shots on the
Chattooga River which is the border part
of the border between Georgia and South
Carolina now at summer camp I was big
into the canoe program we were canoeing
that River keep in mind I'm 12 years old
the counselors decided that we needed to
see the rapids that we were going to be
canoeing and that the best way to show
us these Rapids was to show us the movie
delivery now if you don't know if you
have not seen the movie deliverance Ned
Beatty gets a looses is something I
don't know if you go see it point is we
want he's violate is violating is
violated by another man and it's
actually a phenomenal wonderful powerful
movie terrific but this is a this is a
very disturbing scene in it
and and and the counselors are showing
this to us but they're they're showing
us to look at the rapids so they
fast-forward through the parts that
we're not supposed to see so I'm seeing
at 12 years old Ned Beatty violated in
high-speed okay and I took away from
that a love of banjo
[Applause]